during the height of the pandemic this
Factory exported a record number of
bicycles to the United States but
because of inflation in the U.S and
bilateral trade tensions sales are at
record lows I have joined the business
more than 20 years and many of my
customers University more than 30 40
years they have never experienced the
market as bad as today
reduced foreign demand for Chinese Goods
is just one of the challenges facing the
economy disappointing data for July
points to faltering growth industrial
output grew 3.7 percent from a year
earlier compared to 4.4 percent in June
retail sales Rose by 2.5 percent the
slowest growth since last December
despite the Peaks summer travel season
we are entering this economic downturn
and that has already longer than most
the people had anticipated
um and the main risk now in China is
that it might be locked into this
confidence trap real estate sales have
slumped by 8.5 percent compared to 2022.
the crisis in this sector is deepening
high-profile developer Country Garden
suspended the trade of onshore bonds on
Monday its shares have plunged to a
record low further damaging invested
confidence in the industry that was once
a pillar of economic growth
the government in Beijing is downplaying
concerns
ey some companies are facing
difficulties with desk risk being
somewhat exposed impacting marketing
expectations however it's important to
recognize that these issues are
temporary
a decision to stop publishing youth
unemployment totals every month has
sparked anger online the government says
it needs to improve the way the data is
measured in June the job is rate for
under 24 year olds hit a record high of
21 percent
if you close your eyes then it doesn't
exist read one Comet which was liked
over 5 000 times whether you go to
college or not go to college it's not
very easy to find a job to be honest
this year Lego has sacked half of his
employees he says factories around him
have done the same
in an effort to boost investor
confidence China's Central Bank has cut
a key interest rate for the second time
in recent months Beijing has also eased
restrictions on buying property and
announce policies to increase Auto and
appliance sales but many animals say
these government measures aren't enough
to call the economy out of its current
stock Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing